did you ever in a million years think
that you'd be facutly do celebrating the
reboots of the hills I mean there's
always talked about it and I feel like
Adams evallo the original producer
always wanted start it up again it was
just a matter of time all it's all about
timing sure I know it is the right time
yet on the same page and she has been a
wild ride
I was talking to Justin Bobby earlier
and he made it seem like the door was
maybe still open for you guys what kind
of journey
do you take a thon is no in Justin since
I was a 19 years old it's been so long
and I just feel like we're still filming
um it's been a while dry cake I can't
thank you thing cuz I'm gonna give it up
but just watch and see you guys either
still sparked I think there's always
going to be chemistry between us and
that everyone talks about it it's
whether or not yeah it's all about
timing all about timing know where to
start
yeah right there was some back-and-forth
but whether we'd see your daughter here
on the show are we gonna see her no I
chose not to have her on the show I just
kind of wanted to see what the show is
about because years ago it was more
about going out and partying and like
dating and it's not so I'm just very
protective I'm a mama bear and I just
yeah I just don't want to expose her to
that but I do talk about I do talk about
her a lot okay how could you not right
so I don't film that version of my life
but the version of my life that I do
that the cameras in is with this group
of friends in LA yeah I was watching
today I think it was some video and you
said you wish you never got married
how much of your personal life but are
we gonna see me out talk about it a lot
I just feel like when I got pregnant I
thought the right thing to do is to get
married and I thought I had hope you
know I prayed about it I was like this
is right thing I think I'm just gonna do
it if I don't do it I'll always wonder
so I did it and I learned I mean yeah
though myself getting married ever again
I would love to get married again and I
want like two or three more kids so yeah
what are you looking for in a guy gosh
you know I'm just I'm still healing
right now and I feel like I'm not I
don't know if I'm 100% ready but I
definitely want a guy that's loyal
that's some shade yeah it's my ex though
just which one which one my my
ex-husband um you know the qualities I
look for in a guy know is like respect
respect loyalty honesty there's got to
be a connection chemistry and we gotta
set boundaries you can't there's if
there's three red flags you run away
don't get more than three two chances
like yeah don't be impulsive you sound
so much more grown-up like you learned a
lot I've learned a lot to say the least
you're nervous for fans to see play out
on the show this time around for me I
think in the first episode it's just
when we started filming last August it
was like a really emotional time I was
it was really dark moment and I was
right in the mix of the divorce and
custody battle and Mike I wasn't in a
good place but I still films and I tried
to be happy and the bubbly one but I had
moments of breaking down so I just hate
watching myself cry it sucks
there are a lot of Tears not a lot but
there's a couple
I saw you walking with Stephanie so it
looks like you guys are friendly and on
good terms but there's some drama with
her and Spencer what can you tease about
that I mean I feel like we're all on
good terms at this point we all know
it's reality show we all know there's
things there editing we don't really
know what's gonna happen but at the same
time it's like what I said earlier no
one will actually understand our bond
that we all have for each other we fight
we cry we talk to each other but you
know what we all have each other's back
yeah your family yeah did you reach out
to Lauren by the way before signing on
to get her blessing or two sort of Tata
I don't think anyone did no-one's really
talked to her since this finale I know
Frankie has but you know we all open our
complete separate ways how would you
choose the premiere in one word one word
wild wild wild
[Music]